et à la grande surprise des enquêteurs
d'un seul coup sans aucune raison le
jeune homme passe aux aveux il va nous
nous sortir une une histoire quasiment à
glacer le sang il raconte un scénario
d'un film
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'horreur la Clio jaune de La Poste à
bord de laquelle circulé madame Alem a
été retrouvé jeudi après-midi à Toulouse
en revanche toujours aucune nouvelle de
la mer de famille les enquêteurs
travaillent sur la piste
criminelle Elisabeth Alem 48 ans mère de
famille sans histoire employé à la Poste
a mystérieusement
disparu c'est le début d'une affaire
incroyable un huclot familial diabolique
ce scénario vous ne pouvez pas
l'imaginer vous le voyez dans les
films c'est
inimaginable il raconte un scénario d'un
film
d'horreur va nous nous sortir une une
histoire quasiment à glacer le S je
défendre bah c'est
tué sans lever la tête elle me répond
maman ne reviendra
[Musique]
pas il est midi le 13 juin 2002 à Rodz
dans
l'avyon Elisabeth Alem responsable du
service immobilier de La Poste à
plusieurs heures de retard et cela ne
lui ressemble pas ellisabeth est une
femme de qualité c'est une femme
ponctuelle une femme qui a réussi
professionnellement c'est une dame de 48
ans qui a une vie rangée c'est une femme
de
tempérament très jovial très apprécié de
ses collaborateurs et de ses
équipes au bureau ce jour-là tout le
monde la
cherche France Deltour l'une de ses
collègues a d'ailleurs rendez-vous vous
avec elle en début
d'après-midi à 14h sa secrétaire m'a
appelé pour me demander si j'avais vu
ellisabeth elle m'a dit que le matin
elle c'était pas présentée à son travail
ce qui est assez inhabituel elle
m'explique également qu'elle a essayé de
joindre ses filles entre midier 2h et
que celles-ci sont étonnées de ne pas
avoir eu de nouvelles de leur
mère Elizabeth Alem a 3 enfant et elle
n'a pas l'habitude de les laisser sans
nouvell vez laisser votre message après
le signal encore moins ce
jour-là les filles d'Élisabeth sont
particulièrement inquièes il y en a une
qui qui passait une épreuve du
baccalauréat le matin on ne peut pas
imaginer qu'elle n'it pas pris des
nouvelles qu'elle n'it pas appelé sa
fille pour lui demander comment s'était
passé cette épreuve Élisabeth est une
bonne mère Élisabeth c'est une femme qui
était très proche de ses enfants très
proche des études de ses enfants qui
suivaient les études de ses
enfants les heures
passent personne ne parvient à joindre
Elisabeth téléphone est coupé après le
signal
son en milieu d'après-midi sa secrétaire
très inquiète prévient la police la
secrétaire de
d'Élisabeth n'ayant toujours pas de
nouvelle se décide à contacter le
commissari de police de
Villefranche pour s'inquiéter de
l'absence
d'éliisabeth la nuit tombe sur
Villefranche de rouerg la mère de
famille reste
injoignable
le lendemain sans nouvelles depuis 24 he
les policiers décident de procéder aux
premières
[Musique]
vérification deux choses vont être
vérifié assez rapidement d'abord il
a-t-il eu des mouvements sur les comptes
d'Élizabeth aucun mouvement n'est repéré
et ensuite est-ce que son téléphone
permet de la localiser qu' marche encore
et là on s'aperçoit que ce téléphone ne
fonctionne
plus collègues et les proches
d'éliisabeth sont entendus par les
enquêteurs et un premier élément
apparaît la mère de famille n'était pas
très doué au volant elle conduisait très
mal et cela étéit de notoriété
publique Elisabeth Henri même elle elle
en plaisante avec ses collègues qui la
guettte quand elle arrive pour se garer
pour faire son créneau qu'elle a
toujours beaucoup de mal à faire on la
taquiné parce que l'un de ses collègues
lui donnit des leçons de conduite dans
un premier temps l'hypothèse d'un
accident de la route est donc envisagé
d'ailleurs certains collègues vont
spontanément partir à la recherche de la
voiture jaune de la poste que conduisait
ellisabeth l'un de mes collègues et
moi-même sans nous être concerté lui à
moto moi en voiture nous allons faire
quelques routes qui sont un peu
difficiles dans le département et sur
son trajet parce que à ce moment-là la
végétation est très très importante au
mois de juin et parce qu'on se dit que
peut-être elle a pu avoir un accident et
qu'on l'a pas vu dans cette région très
accidentée la voiture a pu disparaître
au fond d'un
ravin du coup les gendarmes déploient
d'importants moyens pour retrouver la
voiture de fonction de la mère de
famille plusieurs dizaines de de
gendarmes de patrouill auss les routes
un peu du département même voir à
l'extérieur et le survol de toute la
région en hélicoptère mais ces recherche
reste
[Musique]
veine
les enquêteurs cherchent alors à en
savoir un peu plus sur la vie privée de
cette mère de famille qui a disparu sans
laisser aucune trace Élisabeth est
séparée
elle vit de la monnaie avec ses deux
filles il y a Adrien le fils qui est âgé
de 22 ans qui est plus ou moins étudiant
qui lui habite dans le même immeuble que
sa mère et ses deux sœurs mais quelqu
marche a-udessus dans un petit studio my
le père qui vit à Villefranche alors à
quelques ru de là
elle est en instance de divorce c'est
vrai mais bon rien ne laisse penser
qu'elle était affectée oututre mesure
par cette cette décision on ne lui
connait pas de liaison amoureuse côté
professionnel ellisabeth est épanouie et
appréciée de tous elle doit être mutée
sur ville franche d'ailleurs elle elle
est très très heureuse de cette
situation elle a tout pour être heureuse
il y a aucun aucun élément négatif dans
dans dans sa vie de femme son absence
est normal tout ce qui est vérifié dans
son environnement
est personnel et professionnel rien
n'explique cette disparition mais alors
que s'est-il passé ce 13 juin 2002 qui
pourrait expliquer que la postière ne
donne plus de nouvelles grâce au
témoignage de son fils de ses deux
filles et de son mari les enquêteurs
vont pouvoir retracer l'emploi du temps
des le matin de sa disparition et très
vite ils vont s'apercevoir que dans
cette famille tout le monde ne dit pas
la même
[Musique]
chose d'abord les deux filles
d'Élisabeth expliquent avoir vu leur
mère à 6h30 le matin de sa disparition
elle semblait tout à fait normale après
le petit- dééjeuner elle a quitté son
domicile direction La
Poste les deux filles sont ensuite
parties au
[Musique]
lycée
le fils ne donne pas tout à fait la même
version que ses sœurs lui aussi a vu sa
mère mais plus
tard Adrien qui habite donc le petit
studioenant qui a croisé sa mère à 8h30
dans les parties communes de l'immeuble
enfiny le mari a encore une autre
version il explique que sa femme était
bien chez elle ce matin là puisquil
avait justement rendez-vous avec elle
ils ont rendez-vous à 9h pour discter
des modalités de leur
séparation le partage des biens
éventuellement des pensions alimentaires
des différents enfants rendez-vous qui
s'est passé tout à fait dans une ente
cordiale même s'ils sont en séparation
qui dure une dizaine de minutes selon M
il est 9h lorsqu'éliisabeth monte dans
sa voiture de fonction pour rejoindre
son bureau à Rodz à 50 km de là depuis
la mère de famille et sa voiture se sont
volatilisé
alors ces témoignage pose
question plusieurs versions
s'opposent d'un côté celle des
sœurs de l'autre celle du frère et du
père Adrien va expliquer qu'à 8h30 il a
vu sa mère dans son appartement ça colle
pas avec les déclarations des deux sœurs
qui elles sont carré maman est partie à
7h30 on l'a vu de 6 à 7h30 à 7h30 elle
nous embrassé qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
entre 7h30
8h30 elle serait partie revenu qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait pendant une heure ça
c'est un vrai problème ils ont pas la
réponse le 17 juin j'ai saisi la brigade
des recherch pour ouvrir une enquête
préliminaire afin donc de d'étendre les
recherches un appel à témoins est
également lancé dans les journaux
locaux et il faut faire vite car chaque
jour qui passe voit les chances de
retrouver la mère de famille
diminuer le 20 juin une semaine après la
disparition d'Élizabeth Alem l'appel à
témoin porte ses
fruits la Clio jaune de la Poste a été
retrouvée jeudi après-midi non loin de
la gare matabio à Toulouse la voiture de
la mère de famille est garée à 130 km de
son domicile et à 150 de son lieu de
travail cette voiture est intacte elle
est correctement garée fermé à
clé immédiatement les experts de la
gendarmerie passent le véhicule au
peigne fin ils y trouvent de nombreuses
empreintes toutes appartinent à
[Musique]
Élizabeth les gendarmes de Rodz décide
d'aller fouiller l'appartement de la
disparue en plein cœur de ville franche
de
RER on voulez être sûr qu'elle n''est
pas laissé de courriers ou de documents
nous permettant de nous orienter sur ça
sur une recherche sur une destination
mais là encore les recherches ne donnent
rien à partir du moment où le véhicule a
été retrouver qu'on a plus aucune trace
qu'on a aucun document dans son
appartement aucune lettre rien qui peut
nous permettre d'espérer
encore la retrouver à un point précis il
est vrai que que l'enquête s'est
orientée sur la famille et les
enquêteurs vont vite découvrir que la
vie d'Élisabeth était loin d'être aussi
tranquille qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer selon ses collègues elle
avait de nombreux accrochages avec
Adrien son fils de 22
ans Adrien avait des problèmes
d'adolescents Adrien était peut-être
tiraillé entre son père et sa mère il ne
voulait pas travailler il avait plus ou
moins mis un terme à ses
études si éisabeth faisait tout pour
qu'il les reprenne sa mère disait oh là
là il est pas très travailleur il prend
tout à la légère les gendarmes
découvrent aussi que contrairement à ce
que mdialem le mari d'éliisabeth leur a
raconté la procédure de divorce était
conflictuelle Elisabeth évite vraiment
depuis plusieurs mois de rencontrer as
son mari elle faisait tout pour le pour
le fuir le divorce se réglait par avocat
interposé leur relation était d'autant
plus tendu que Medy ne travaillait pas
et n'avait aucune ressource
financière c'est un homme qui a une
façade qui veut donner une importance
qu' n'a pas vraiment il se dit
diplômé expert comptable professeur
d'économie l'enquête révèle
effectivement qui n'avait jamais exercé
de profession on savait pas trop s'il
avait véritablement les diplômes qu'il
disait avoir il se présentait comme un
penseur mais bon audelà de ça ça donait
pas grand-chose un adolescent qui ne
s'entend pas avec sa
mère une procédure de divorce tendue il
n'en faut pas moins aux enquêteurs pour
faire du mari et du Fils d'Élisabeth des
suspects
[Musique]
potentiels
le 21 juin les gendarmes mettent en
place un système
d'écoute les conversations téléphoniques
du Père et du Fils sont dissqués et 8
jours après la disparition d'Élizabeth
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas
inquiets dans ces écoutes les deux
personnes vont pas exprimer leurs
craintes leurs inquiétudes leurs
questionnements sur la disparition de de
leur mère et femme ils en parlent
quasiment pas et quand ils en parlent
ils pas il don pas l'air d'être inquiet
fait étrange les gendarmes s'aperçoivent
qu'au téléphone les deux hommes sont
obsédés par
l'enquête on s'est fait super interroger
sur
toi sur comment on travaillait sur la
façon dont tu gagnais de l'argent des
trucs comme
ça sur les rapports qu'elle avait avec
toi qu'elle avait avec
moi comment ça s'est passé ces derniers
temps
moi je pense qu'il cherche à entourer à
regarder comment à cerner les trucs
affectifs l'attitude du Père et du Fils
pose question et les gendarmes ne vont
pas tarder à découvrir qu'en fait les
deux hommes ont menti interrogé sur leur
emploi du temps le jour de la
disparition d'Élizabeth MDY et Adrien
ont déclarer être parti ensemble le 13
juin à Toulouse il devait y passer
l'après-midi seulement leurs téléphones
disent tout autre chose quand on va
faire les déclenchements de relais on va
se rendre compte que le 13 juin
après-midi alors qu'ils avaient dit se
rendre à Toulouse tous les deux à bord
d'une seule voiture il se téléphone
entre eux et là on se dit si se parle au
téléphone c'est que ils sont pas la même
voiture pourquoi ce mensonge Adrien et
my cache-t-il quelque
chose dès le lendemain les gendarmes
passent le studio du jeune homme au
peignefin pour ne rien laisser au hasard
les experts utilisent un produit
révélateur de trac de sang le blu
St on va commencer le BL St dans la
salle de bain et on a quelque chose on a
quelque chose on a des prélèvements à
faire à cet endroit là et cette affaire
on est peut-être en train de commencer à
dérouler la pelotte les techniciens en
identification criminelle poursuivent
dans la chambre
d'Adrien et en déplçant un
me couverte en le déplaçant alors là si
nous étions déjà suspicieux c'est on va
l'être encore plus parce que en fait
compte il cache une partie du mur ou
comme par hasard il manque une partie de
de la tapisserie et lorsqu'il vaporise
le bluest le résultat est immédiat des
nombreuses traces de sang sont encore
visibles on avait des réactions
disséinées sur une grande surface du mur
on voyait bien les formes d'éponges qui
avaient servi à nettoyer on avait sur
d'autres endroit qui était très
difficile d'accès d'autres réactions qui
avaient également été été nettoyé
quelque chose sétait déroulé à cet
endroit les enquêteurs le savent
désormais quelqu'un a abondamment saigné
dans le studio du fils
d'éliisabeth des prélèvements sont
immédiatement envoyés pour expertise et
dès le lendemain le rapport d'analyse
sanguiné sans
[Musique]
appel le résultat génétique qui va être
obtenu c'est le sang de de la victime
pour les gendarmes il ne s'agit plus
d'une disparition
inquiétante mais bien d'un
homicide le 30 juin 2002 adrien est
convoqué à la gendarmerie de Rodez et
placé en garde à vue pour meurtre
étonnemment il n' pas vraiment de
réaction il a pas l'air vraiment surpris
on a l'impression qu'il s'attend mais ça
plus au même moment Medy le père en
vacances à 650 km de là est
interpellé nous localisons mie sur blanc
Ménil donc banlieu
parisienne extrêmement surpris de notre
de notre présence pendant que les
enquêteurs le transfèrent dans les
locaux de la gendarmerie
l'interrogatoire d'Adrien le fils a déjà
commencé il reste de volte il l'affaire
on dirait que l'affaire lui passe
au-dessus de la tête si je peux
m'exprimer qu'est-il arrivé dans son
studio le jeune homme de 22 ans a-t-il
tué sa mère les gendarmes ont 48 he pour
obtenir des
réponses face à l'adjudant chef mermose
Adrien détaille son emploi du temps
Adrien indique que le 12 au soir ils ont
regardé la télévision avec un copain qui
l'appelle Matthéo jusqu'à 34h du matin à
7h30 il se
réveille Matthéo quitte les lieux il a
eu sa mère vers 8h30 il s'est un peu
accroché avec elle parce qu'il
travaillait pas
bien Adrien raconte qu'après la dispute
avec sa mère il est parti promener son
chien il est catégorique Élisabeth était
vivante lorsqu'il l'a quitté il revient
à son appartement il entreouvre la porte
laisse rentrer le chien jette la laiss
et repart il est allé dans le petit café
au Globe son père l'a rejoint à cet
endroit
il boivent ensemble ver et ils repartent
un peu plus tard dans l'après-midi il
est allé à Toulouse avec son père
seulement les gendarmes le savent
pertinemment Adrien ment il ne s'est pas
rendu avec son père à Toulouse comme
l'ont d'ailleurs prouvé les relevés
téléphoniques de leur
portable on va s'attacher à lui faire
comprendre que l'histoire du voyage avec
son père à Toulouse au vu des éléments
qu'on a sur le téléphone ça ça la
route confronté à ses mensonges le jeune
homme va finir par craquer et il fait
une surprenante
[Musique]
révélation Adrien va admettre que
effectivement il n'est pas parti avec
son père mais qu'il est descendu avec la
Clio de de sa mère qui l'a garé à
Toulouse où il l'a
abandonné comment expliquez-vous la
présence de la voiture de fonction de
votre mère à Toulouse c'est moi qui l'ai
amené égaré à toulouseavezv fait
je les ai jeté dans une
poubelle pourquoi Adrien a-t-il emprunté
la voiture de sa
mère pourquoi s'en est-il débarrassé que
s'est-il réellement
passé il est minuit cela fait 12h que le
jeune homme est en garde à vue il va
alors révéler une réalité
tragique avez-vous participé de quelque
manière que ce soit à la disparition de
votre
mère oui une participation légère vous
pouvez donc nous dire ce qui lui est
arrivé est-elle vivante ou décédée je ne
peux pas vous dire exactement ce qui lui
est arrivé par contre il est vrai que ma
mère est
décédée Elizabeth Alem est donc
morte mais il s'agirait en fait d'un
accident il va dire qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose mais qu'il n'a rien
fait dans le processus
mortel selon Adrien tout se serait joué
le 13 juin après avoir vu sa mère il
sort promener son chien et c'est ensuite
que le drame se serait
joué selon lui quand il revient au
moment où il ramène son chien à
l'appartement il trouve son son pèreme
sa mère à côté de lui et le visage
ensanglanté son père tout de suite va
lui lu expliquer ce qui s'est passé va
lui donner donc sa version d'un accident
d'une d'un homicide donc involontaire
mais tout de suite il va lui dire qu'il
faut que tu m'aides et cette aide qui
lui qui lui demande donc c'est ben c'est
de participer à la disparition du
corps le fils obéit à son père et
s'exécute il vient de perdre sa mère il
veut pas perdre son
père les deux hommes auraient alors
enveloppé le corps dans une bâche avant
de le charger dans une voiture de
location
ils aurai décidé de faire croire à une
fugue en abandonnant la voiture
d'Élizabeth à Toulouse descendre à
Toulouse avec la voiture sa mère son
père descend le récupérer à Toulouse
avec le Kangou dans lequel se trouve le
corps de
[Musique]
d'Élisabeth Adrien ne donne aucune
explication concernant les circonstances
exactes de l'accident dont sa mère
aurait été
victime au même dans une salle
d'interrogatoire toute proche l'adjudant
chef Buck commence à interroger
Medy l'homme ignore totalement que son
fils vient de le mettre en cause dans la
mort de sa femme au début de la garde à
vue il est bien évident que moi je ne
lui donne aucun
élément que nous avons notre possession
et je lui je le laisse parler M dit le
père est sûr de lui il n'a rien à voir
avec la disparition d'Élisabeth il
persiste elle était vivante quand il l'a
quitté à
9h15 seulement lorsqu'il apprend que
l'analyse de son portable prouve qu'il
n'était pas avec son fils sur la route
de Toulouse l'homme fait des aveux très
rapidement my finalement donc se se met
à évoluer dans ses déclarations il se
rend donc à la demande de d'Élisabeth à
son domicile pour discuter du
divorce le couple monte dans le studio
d'Adrien pour faire l'inventaire de
quelques biens à
partager et c'est là que le ton serait
monté et que la situation aurait
dégénéré
elle folle de rageur attattrapé une
raquette de tennis et lui en aurait mis
un grand coup sur
l'épaule prend à ce momentl une pelle et
frappe à la tête
Elizabeth un seul coup de pelle elle est
morte il quitte à ce momentl le domicile
de son fils
en ville pour le rencontrer et lui
demande de conduire la fonction
d'Élisabeth à Toulouse sans lui
expliquer le
motif jusque là les versions du Père et
du Fils semblent
coller la thèse de la dispute qui a mal
tourné semble crédible et à ce moment
précis de la garde à vue affirme
qu'Adrien son fils n'a rien à voir avec
la disparition du
cadavre quelques instants plus tard
l'interrogatoire d'Adrien reprend dans
la salle d'à côté et le jeune homme va
immédiatement contredir les déclarations
de son
père ds la reprise l'audition il nous
dit voilà je je consent à vous amener où
nous avons déposé le corps de de ma mère
on le prend de la voiture et on fonce à
l'endroit qui nous
indique le terrainù O se trouve c'est un
espèce de prê de C sur à concot dans le
lotre à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de Villefranche de rouerg et à quelques
mètres à peine de la route Adrien
désigne les restes d'un
feu et là se trouvent les restes
carbonisés
d'Élisabeth la zone est immédiatement
quadrillée les experts procèdent à de
nombreux prélèvements
de retour à la gendarmerie Adrien le
fils est sommet de s'expliquer le jeune
homme se lance dans un terrible récit
sans la moindre émotion Adrien dit avoir
lui-même incendié le
[Musique]
corps ils l'ont laissé en train de
brûler ils sont repartis tous les deux
pour
vilopage le lendemain c'està-dire le 14
juin au matin il est retourné sur les
lieux pour voir euh où on était la la
crémation du corps là il s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait le corps n'avait pas
complètement brûlé et il a éparpillé ce
qui restait euh un peu plus loin pour
dissimuler le dissimuler ce
corps de son côté my le père est
catégorique son fils n'est au courant de
rien et n'a rien
fait seulement l'homme va bien devoir se
rendre à
l'évidence à ce moment-là donc je lui
donne l'élément fatal à savoir que son
fils Adrien
reconnaît avoir participé au à la à la
disparition du corps de sa mère réaction
stupéfaite et oui laquèe en disant
effectivement
adrien a participé avec moi à la
suppression du corps
mais n'était pas présent le matin
lorsque je je tue
Élisabeth le père tente une nouvelle
fois de minimiser le rôle de son fils il
endosse toute la responsabilité de la
crémation du corps
d'Élisabeth alors Medy assume tout seul
cet acte en disant qu'il asperge le
corps d'Élisabeth et ses effets
personnels son sac qui contient portable
et et
papier il met le feu alors al que adrien
est retourné au
véhiculey à la fin de de sa déclaration
explique que il demande à son fils
Adrien le lendemain de retourner sur les
lieux pour confirmer que le corps a bien
été brûlé et qu'il ne reste plus de
trace
d'Élisabeth à l'issue de leur garde à
vue my et Adrien hem sont mis en examen
pour le meurtre de leur mère et épouse
ils sont placés en détention
provisoire plusieurs Z d'ombre
subsiste s'agit-il réellement d'une
dispute qui aurait mal tourné qui a
procédé à la crémation du corps les
gendarmes ne vont pas tarder à découvrir
que le père et le fils n'ont pas dit
toute la
vérité car 15 jours après la découverte
du corps le rapport d'autopsie va
totalement réorienter
l'enquête les causes de la mort c'est
pas le atisme facial en revanche elle
porte des traces de coup elle a la
mâchoire fracturée elle a des côtes
cassé j'ai porté un seul coup de
pelle les experts disent non le médecin
non il y a eu plusieurs coups mais ses
coues ne sont pas mortelles elle est
morte par
asphixie aucun des deux n'avait fait
d'une éventuelle asphyie et dit lui
avait dit qu'il n'avait porté qu'un coup
en se
défendant donc ils ont
menti dès lors l'affaire va prendre une
tournure pour le moins
inattendue les enquêteurs ont repris
toutes les auditions depuis le début du
dossier il compris toutes les personnes
qui avaient donc croisé le chemin de la
disparue ou croisé le chemin des proches
de la disparue et parmi eux l'un des
amis d'Adrien cet ami Matthéo polarski a
été interrogé en qualité de témoin à
deux reprises par les
gendarmes le jeune homme a raconté en
détail sa journée du 13 juin et quelques
éléments ne sont pas très
clairs Mato on commence à s'intéresser à
lui parce que d'abord il revient souvent
dans les déclarations d'Adrien sur
l'emploi du temps du 13 juin il dort
dans son App la veille des fa il se
réveille le matin à 7h alors qu'il av
jus 4h et rien de particulier à faire il
travaille pas pouroi à 7 et ce n'est pas
tout dans son audition Mato polarski
raconte qu'il est repé chez Adrien vers
10h30 le matin du drame il dit n'oir
rienarqué de
particulier les enquêteurs savent grâce
à son fils qu'Élisabeth vient de mourir
dans le
studio
et ça Matthéo n'en parle pas là on se
dit il y a quand même sil parle de rien
c'est qu'il a quand même quelque chose
qu'a vu Matthéo le 13 juin en sait-il
plus qu'il ne le dit les gendarmes étudi
ces allé venu le jour du drame et ils
vont faire une découverte
surprenante le directeur d'enquête me
demande donc d'effectuer la téléphonie
du 13 juin sur le téléphone de Mato
Po et là donc je termine que cette
journée du 13 juin à 12h22 il déclenche
le même relais que my
àem que faisait-il avec
mdialem le 19 novembre 2002 le jeune
homme est placé en garde à vue
laadjud en chef mermose mène
l'interrogatoire c'est quelqu'un de très
calme à la limite d'être d'être froid
dans un premier temps il a été assez euh
circonspect et à la grande surprise des
enquêteurs d'un seul coup sans aucune
raison le jeune homme passe aux
aveux il va n nous sortir une une
histoire quasiment à glacer le sang il
raconte un scénario d'un film
d'horreur durant de longues heures
mattho polarski livre un récit très
complet de la journée du 13
juin pour lui il ne s'agit pas d'une
dispute qui aurait mal tourné mais d'un
terrible complot un complot
familial et tout aurait commencé par un
rendez-vous surréaliste avec Adrien dans
un café quelques jours avant le le
meurtre d'Élisabeth Adrien l' l'
interprend lui disant je voudrais tuer
quelqu'un est-ce que tu voudrais
[Musique]
m'aider j'ai répondu oui sans hésitation
et très sérieusement je n'ai plus posé
de question donc le le lendemain ou le
surlendemain il va chez Adrien il passe
la soirée à regarder des des
DVD et Adrien lui annonce et ben le le
meurtre c'est pour demain il s'agit de
tuer ma
mère en écoutant Matthéo les enquêteurs
sont abazourdis par le détachement du
jeune
homme
comment se fait-il que vous puissiez
accepter de lui fournir de l'aide pour
commettre un meurtre sans poser la
moindre
question c'est comme ça chez moi je suis
comme ça avez-vous essayé de dissuader
Adrien oui brièvement mais il ne voulait
en faire qu'à sa tête et j'ai compris
que c'était pas la peine
d'insister avec la même distance Matthéo
poursuit ses aveux
glaçants il est 7h30 le 13 juin 2002
lorsque le macabre projet est mis à
exécution
d'après la version de
[Musique]
Matthéo adrien a attiré sa mère dans sa
chambre maman
d'ord il dit à sa mère viens pe voir je
prépare une surprise pour une des filles
je vais te bander de tes yeux assie-toi
sur une
chaise pendant ce temps my est dissimulé
à la salle bain Matthéo va l'appeler en
lui disant voilà c'est bon tu peux venir
c'est le moment my arrive armée d'une
pelle entourée de chiffon il donne un
coup sur la tête de sa femme
elle est toujours
vivante Adrien va s'emparer de la pelle
et donner des
coups sa mère tombe au sol toujours
consciente et à ce momentl elle lui
demande mais mais qu'est-ce que tu fais
Adrien et Adrien lui dit ben tu vois je
te frappe puis sentant qu'il n'arrivait
pas à Chever sa mère il prend l'appel
laattend à mattho celui-ci donne encore
quelques coups sur la sur la tête de
d'Élisabeth et Matthéo avec un sangfroid
extraordinaire
raconte je vais prendre un coussin et
comme elle vit encore je vais
l'étouffer je suis resté 20 à 30 minutes
jusqu'à ce que je sois sûr qu'elle était
morte je sais que ma copine m'a
téléphoné pendant ce temps je lui ai
répondu que je la rappellerai plus tard
car j'étais
occupé d'après Mato posk les hmesurors
de faç de faire disparaître le corps
d'Élisabeth Matthéo va aller chercher
une bâche agricole dans un magasin et il
explique qu'ils vont rouler la victime
dans cette bâche pour pouvoir la
transporter donc vers mid et demi
descendre le corps de la victime et il
le charge dans le Kangou qui a été placé
dans la petite rue où on peut à peine
manœuvrer Adrien se rent alors à
Toulouse avec la Clio de la poste de sa
mère de leur côté M et Matthéo partent
au volant de la voiture de location ils
veulent se débarrasser du corps ils sont
allés quasiment jusqu'à corde c'est là
d'ailleurs qu'on relève la similitude
entre les relais déclenchés par leur
téléphone voyant qu'il trouvaient pas
d'endroit B ils sont revenus sur ville
franche et là ils se sont séparé le
corps va rester toute la journée dans la
voiture de
location dans la soirée les trois hommes
se retrouvent chez ellisabeth et c'est
vers 23h30 qu'il quitte
Villefanche
ils arrivent à Concord s'il trouent le
lieu idéal à leurs yeux pour se
débarrasser du
corps ils vont décharger ce
corps et Matthéo affirme que c'est lui
seul qui a brûlé le corps
d'Élisabeth j'ai tout fait
instinctivement j'ai mis directement le
feu je resté 20 à 30
minutes je suis parti le feu était
toujours allumé je m'étais cependant
assuré que la végétation ne puisse pas
s'enflammer le lendemain le 14 juin
Adrien et Matthéo décident de retourner
sur place voir comment s passé la
crémation du corps ils se rendent compte
qu'en fait le corps n'a pas complètement
disparu et là ils éparpillent des
morceaux pour essayer de le
dissimuler c'est la dernière phase de ce
crime qui est aussi horrible que que les
premières phases qui ont été raconté par
Matthéo pour l'adjud en chef mermose
aucun doute Matthéo dit la vérité et
pour
cause la version de Matthéo tient la
route et d'autant plus que elle semble
plutôt correspondre avec les résultats
de l'autopsie puisqueon nous a parlé de
plusieurs coups sur le sur la tête de
d'Élisabeth et surtout des essais
parasphixie d'essais par
asphixie seul les enquêteurs connaissent
la véritable cause de la mort
d'Élisabeth et seul quelqu'un qui a
participé au meurtrre pouvait mentionner
un tel
détail pour les gendarmes les aveux de
Matthéo polarski sont le tournant de
l'enquête à l'issue de sa garde à vue le
jeune homme est mis en examen pour
assassinat et placé en détention
[Musique]
provisoire de leur côté my et Adrien ni
farouchement selon eux Matthéo affabu il
n'était pas là
cependant pour la juge d'instruction les
trois hommes ont certainement participé
à la mise à mort d'éliisabeth reste à
savoir pourquoi quel est le mobile de ce
crime à première vue Matthéo le copain
n'avait aucune raison de tuer Élisabeth
lorsqu'il est interrogé par les
gendarmes par le jus instruction il
décrit quelqu'un de très
bien une mère aimante pour ses enfants
une une femme envers laquelle il n'a
absolument aucun griief Matthéo il a une
une explication qui est assz assez
déroutante ils m'ont proposé de les
aider c'était un boulot comme un autre
et j'ai tout simplement accepté sans
chercher à en savoir
plus pour les gendarmes une hypothèse
simpose mattho aurait été payé pour
participer à l'assassinat
d'Élisabeth seulement ils font fausse
route auriez-vous touché de l'argent
pour participer à ce meurtre non en
aucun cas je n'ai pas non plus été
menacé face à une telle froideur les
enquêteurs sont stupéfait et ils vont
trouver un début d'explication à cette
attitude détachée en explorant le passé
du jeune
homme l'histoire de Matthéo est une
histoire que je qualifierai dehors norme
Mato posk oui c'est
un jeune homme né en
Colombie qui a grandi dans la rue il est
abandonné par ses
parents pour survivre il faut se
battre soumis à la prostitution dit-il
Sant les godasses il dit c'est ça a été
6 ans d'enfer et cela l'a marqué
énormément avec cette sorte de d'éthique
de la rue qui est d'abord la solidarité
entre copains ces gosses qui n'ont pas
d'affection qui sont seuls vont
construire dans la bande et le groupe de
copains une sorte d'idéalité pour
lesquelles ben on meurt pour l'autre
Matthéo aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître aurait tout simplement rendu
service à son ami
Adrien quand Adrien lui demande de
l'aide c'est plus fort que tout l'amitié
est plus forte que tout et il lui rend
ce service c'est quelque chose qui nous
dépasse tous lui il l' indiqué on m'a
demandé mon aide je l'ai
donné
voilà mais alors quel est le mobile de
My et d'Adrien
hem la réponse les enquêteurs vont
l'obtenir en fouillant la mémoire des
ordinateurs du Père et du
Fils car les deux homme avait monté une
arnaque à l'aide de faux bulletin de pay
fait souscrire des crédits à la
consommation ils allaient retirer le
capital qui était versé en
liquide cette arnaque leur a permis de
récolter un pactol près de 38000 € mais
Elisabeth aurait découvert le potorose
et les aurait menacé de les dénoncer au
fisque Elisabeth était très inquiète par
les affaires auxquelles pouvait se
livrer Adrien EDI mais elle n'aurait
jamais admis qu'Adrienne trampe dans ce
type
d'affaire d'après Adrien la mort de sa
mère lui permettait d'être plus
tranquille pour mettre en œuvre ce
projet
il pensait qu'elle aurait sans cesse
posé des questions quant à l'origine de
l'argent qu'il aurait pu posséder j'ai
appris au moment des faits que le père
d'Adrien avait peur que sa femme le
dénonce au fisque si jamais ellisabeth
les dénonce ils sont fich le rêve s'env
quoi pour la juge d'instruction le
mobile est donc
financier mais après 4 années d'enquête
et de nombreuses confrontations
impossible d'établir avec certitude ce
qu'il s'est passé dans le petit studio
d'Adrien le fils a-t-il effectivement
frappé sa mère le père l'a-t-il tué seul
Matthéo est-il celui qui a achev la
merre de son meilleur ami c'est
maintenant la justice de trancher les
trois hommes sont renvoyés devant la
Cour d'assise pour assassina mais rien
ne va se passer comme prévu le 4 août
2006 il va y avoir un véritable coup de
théâtre on est à pratiquement à 8
semaines du procès on apprend que my a
mis fin à séjour en
prison comme dit le l'administration
pénitentière il s'est accroché il s'est
pendu mais avant de mourir mdialem le
Père a envoyé un mot d'adieu à sa
sœur il a écrit une lettre c'est l'âge
pour
partir pour la paix de la famille Adrien
sera in
santé
je pense que my l'a fait vraiment pour
permettre à Adrien de pouvoir avoir une
version où lui n'existant plus on
pourrait
peut-être faire porter le phardau au
Père geste altruiste d'un père envers
son fils ou fuite désespérée d'un homme
qui n'a pas le courage de faire face au
juré impossible de répondre est-ce la
peur de de se voir mise à nu de voir son
passé décorti
de voir le de se voir déboulonner de son
pieddestal est-ce que c'est perdre la
face face à son fils qui lui a fait peur
Medy emporte ses secrets dans la tombe
ils ne seront que deux à comparaître
pour assassinat devant la Cour d'assise
de
l'avyon le 25 septembre 2006 le procès
s'ouvre à
Rodz Matthéo sk et Adrien allem sont
accusés
d'assassinat l'ambiance est tendue car
il s'agit fait rarissime d'un
matricide pour la première fois depuis 4
ans Adrien Alem fait face à ses sœurs ça
a été un procès extraordinaire avec
notamment les deux sœurs qui vont
assister à l'intégralité du procès es
attendent des des aveux d'ailleurs de
mémoire l'une d'entre elles va lui dire
mais j'attends que tu reconnaisses dans
le box les accusés restent de
[Musique]
marbre ils sont relativement fermés tous
les deux d'abord il se parlent très peu
se regardent même très peu je dirais que
adrien est assez arrogant tandis que
Matthéo est plus effacé après l'examen
des faits les deux accusés campent sur
leur position
Adrien niit avoir tué sa mère il a juste
aidé son père à faire disparaître le
corps Matthéo lui affirme devant la cour
que son ami a frappé ellzabeth un fait
certain c'est que MDY Adrien et Matthéo
à un moment donné se sont retrouvés dans
le petit studio d'Adrien un fait certain
c'est que ces trois personnes ont
participé de près ou de loin soit à
l'exécution
ou à l'accident ou à l'assassinat soit à
la disparition du cadavre la question
que la Cour d'Assise devait trancher
c'est de déterminer les niveaux de
responsabilité qui avait fait quoi et
pourquoi mais surtout y a-t-il eu
préméditation Adrien et Matthéo
avaient-ils l'intention de tuer
ellizabeth ce matin-là pour leurs
avocats il n'y a aucune preuve ne
serait-ce que l'arme c'est tout sauf une
arme dans le cadre d'une préméditation
c'est vraiment l'objet que l'on prend au
dernier
moment pour assiner donc un coup à à
quelqu'un mais ce n'est pas tout pour la
défense le jour ne pouvait pas être plus
mal
choisi on va donc nous expliquer qu'on a
décidé planifié de tuer cette pauvre
femme alors qu'elle est attendue à son
boulot et que sa plus sa fille la plus
âgée passe la première épreuve du bac
nous sommes avec une version qui ne peut
pas coller avec la préméditation qui
nécessite encore une fois de se mettre
d'accord sur un lieu sur une arme sur un
mobile voilà et donc c'est ce que nous
avons combattu en revanche pour la
partie civile aucun doute comme la
longuement décriateéo le crime a été
prémédité pour la famille qui
connaissait parfaitement le dossier qui
a assisté au débat et entendu les
déclarations de Matthéo ça s'est passé
comme il l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
ils l'ont tué à
trois après 5 jours d'audience Matthéo
et Adrien sont condamnés à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour l'assassinat
d'éliisabeth l'horreur dans laquelle
s'est produite la disparition la
crémation de ce corps la dispersion des
restes de la victime a rejailli sur la
le crime que les jurés dev dev dev
juger le jugement est confirmé en appel
Adrien le fils forme alors un pourvoi en
cassation en 2010 un 3è procès a donc
lieu